dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaife
in this series we often talk about smoke
and fluid simulations
and sometimes the examples showcase a
beautiful smoke plume
but not much else however in real
production
environments these simulations often
involve complex scenes
with many objects that interact with
each other and
therein lies the problem computing these
interactions is called
coupling and it is very difficult to get
right but is necessary for many of the
scenes you will see
throughout this video this new graphics
paper builds on a technique
called the lattice boltzmann method and
promises a better way to compute this
two-way coupling
for instance in this simulation two-way
coupling is required
to compute how this fiery smoke trail
propels the rocket
upward so coupling means interaction
between different kinds of objects
but what about the two-way part what
does that mean exactly
well first let's have a look at one-way
coupling
as the box moves here it has an effect
on the smoked plume around it
this example also showcases one-way
coupling where the falling plate stirs
up the smoke around it
the parts with the higher reynolds
numbers showcase more turbulent flows
typically that's the real good stuff if
you ask me
and now on to two-way coupling in this
case
similarly to previous ones the boxes are
allowed to move the smoke
but the added two-way coupling part
means that now
the smoke is also allowed to blow away
the boxes
what's more the vortices here on the
right were even able
to suspend the red box in the air for a
few seconds
an excellent demonstration of a
beautiful phenomenon
now let's look at the previous example
with the dropping plate
and see what happens
yes indeed as the plate drops it moves
the smoke
and as the smoke moves it also blows
away the boxes
due to improvements in the coupling
computation it also simulates
these kinds of vertices much more
realistically than previous works
just look at all this magnificent
progress in just
two years so what else can we do with
all this
what are the typical scenarios that
require accurate two-way coupling
well for instance it can perform an
incredible tornado simulation that you
see here
and there is an alternative view where
we only see the objects moving about
so all this looks good but really how do
we know
how accurate this technique is and now
comes my favorite part
and this is when we let reality be our
judge
and compare the simulation results with
real world experiments
hold on to your papers while you observe
the real experiment here
on the left and now the algorithmic
reproduction of the same scene
here how close are they goodness
very very close i will stop the footage
at different times so we can both
evaluate it better love it
the technique can also undergo the wind
tunnel test here is the real footage
and here is the simulation
and it is truly remarkable how close
this is able to match it
and i was wondering that even though as
someone who has been doing fluids for a
while now
if someone cropped this part of the
image and told me
that it is real word footage i would
have believed it in a second
absolute insanity so how much do we have
to wait to compute a simulation like
this
well great news it uses your graphics
card which is typically the case for the
more rudimentary fluid simulation
algorithms out there
but the more elaborate ones typically
don't support it
or at least not without a fair amount of
additional effort
the quickest example was this as it was
simulated
in less than six seconds which i find to
be
mind-blowing a smoke simulation with box
movements
in a few seconds i am truly out of words
the rocket launch scene took the longest
with 16 hours
while the falling plate example with the
strong draft that threw the boxes around
with about four and a half hours of
computation time
the results depend greatly on delta t
which is the size of the time steps
or in other words in how small
increments we can advance time
when creating these simulations to make
sure we don't miss any important
interactions
you see here that in the rocket example
we have to simulate roughly
a hundred thousand steps for every
second of video footage
no wonder it takes so long we have an
easier time with this scene
where these time steps can be 50 times
larger without losing any detail
and hence it goes much faster the grid
resolution
also matters a great deal which
specifies how many spatial points the
simulation has to take place in
the higher the resolution of the grid
the larger the region we can cover
and the more details we can simulate as
most research works this technique
doesn't come without limitations however
it is less accurate if we have
simulations involving thin
rods and shells and typically uses two
to three times more memory than a
typical simulator program
if these are the only trade-offs to
create all this marvelous footage
sign me up this very second overall this
paper is extraordinarily well written
and of course it has been accepted to
the sigraph conference
one of the most prestigious scientific
venues in computer graphics research
huge congratulations to the authors and
if you wish to see something beautiful
today
make sure to have a look at the paper
itself in the video description
truly stunning work what a time to be
alive
this episode has been supported by
lambda gpu cloud
if you're looking for inexpensive cloud
gpus for ai
check out lambda gpu cloud they've
recently launched
quadro rtx 6000 rtx 8000
and v100 instances and hold on to your
papers
because lambda gpu cloud can cost less
than half
of aws and azure plus they are the only
cloud service with 48 gigabyte
rdx 8000 join researchers at
organizations like apple mit and caltech
in using lambda cloud instances
workstations or servers
make sure to go to lambdalabs.com
to sign up for one of their amazing gpu
instances today
our thanks to lambda for their
long-standing support and for helping us
make better videos for you thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and i'll see you next time